hundreds of people scrambled for space
as they wait to take anything being
handed to them
desperate for months the young and old
gathered in the main Square in the city
of kherson
a woman hands her baby to a volunteer as
she struggles in the crowd
donated clothes toys food diapers and
other supplies all are needed in a city
now back under Ukrainian control after
nine months of occupation
two children help this man carry a sack
of potatoes as he struggles with the
load
officials say Russians destroyed
critical infrastructure before
retreating earlier this month
there's no running water electricity or
Central Heating
for many life is hard but the nightmare
is over
what scared us most was the prospect of
someone ratting you out for having a pro
Ukrainian position you'd be taken to a
prison you could go outside and never
come back I was pregnant when the war
started
the first train since Russia's Invasion
began in February arrives in Curson from
Capital cave its flamboyant colors
painted by local artists reflect a mood
of joy
and it's time for reunions
this father is meeting his son for the
first time in eight months
I feel happiness huge happiness I will
shout out to the world and glory to
Ukraine as Ukraine's forces move into
Villages like these they're ready to
find evidence of any war crimes like
they did in Butcher kharkiv and other
cities after Russian withdrawal
the village of Olex sandrifka was
captured early on it's been heavily
mined
several people were reportedly killed by
Russian forces while trying to escape
we started to examine the dam there was
artillery and mortar shelling many
vehicles were destroyed civilians died
Russia annexed the region of Curson
along with three others in September
pledging to defend them with all
available military means
but now Ukrainian troops say they are
here to stay
Sharif Al Jazeera